behind this door the pressure building
the prime minister gone to ground
the cameras all on him the media mps
members of the public want answers did
the prime minister apologize
this cabinet minister into the front
door today but most keen to avoid
awkward questions here's the foreign
secretary into number 10 via the back
door
whichever way you look at this it's not
good the deputy leader of the opposition
angela reyna
[Applause]
labour demanding answers over the
alleged downing street party on may the
20th when the country was in lockdown
but the pm a no-show sending out a proxy
in his place his mps too steering clear
of this mess look at the conservative
benches i apologize again unreservedly
for the upset that these allegations
have caused but this apology no way near
enough to appease either side of the
chamber the prime minister should come
here now
[Applause]
why can't all the dirty linen be washed
at once why are we getting this drip
drip
feed
of parties
there was anger
there was frustration but what was
hardest was the upset from those mps
like many in the country who lost loved
ones while following the rules in
northern ireland we reached a milestone
of three thousand deaths to recover
three thousand people who
who followed the rules and grave today
so we'll look paymaster i'm putting my
mother-in-law who died alone
keep going well well the paint master
general confirmed there will be a film
and complete disclosure tell them in the
police
service to the other kids almost done
decently
and this now the drum beat of mr
johnson's opponents if the prime
minister
broke the law he will resign won't he
it's an entirely hypothetical position
the prime minister's going nowhere
digging in but the accusations serious
the latest scandal relates to this man
martin reynolds one of the pm's top
officials seen here drinking with mr and
mrs johnson in the downing street garden
on may the 15th 2020 just days after
this gathering he sent an email to up to
a hundred downing street staff inviting
them to bring their own booze to the
garden to celebrate a busy period on may
the 20th this a time when social
gatherings were banned
conservative leaders demanding answers
if he has it not been truthful then that
is an extremely important issue and i've
said previously if the prime minister
has misled parliament then he must
resign boris johnson repeatedly told
parliament that he hadn't broken any
rules but that's now been openly
questioned and investigated by a top
whitehall
official the prime minister and his team
could also face a police investigation
by the met and his mps are watching and
waiting i'm told even his allies are in
despair for now the prime minister is
brazening it out i'm told by source that
at cabinet today he was full of mission
and purpose bulldozing everybody in the
room
but for all the bravado this is a moment
of acute political danger even those mps
backing him are finding it increasingly
tough this is a
distraction while it is obviously
a serious matter
i do think we need to focus on the
issues at hand do you feel a bit
irritated by it
well i think the whole country probably
feels a bit irritated by
and
and in some cases probably more than
that
and as the pm stays holed up in number
10 tonight irritation is giving way to
growing anger this wants vote winning
people pleasing pm now in serious danger
with the public and his party too beth
rigby sky news westminster